I think you should know you saved my
life
[Music]
that singer-songwriter Andy Grammer is
deeply personal single as you see it's
called save my life also you've probably
been hearing one of grammar's songs good
company on CBS we'd like that because a
version of it is a talks theme song and
we're using it in some other fun ways
yeah we like Andy Grammer around here
and he joins us here in studio I like
let's start with save my life I love all
the three that you have out now Andy but
let's start with save my life because I
love the video that you did and the
backstory behind it yeah so I lost my
mom when I was 25 and her best friend
became my godmother immediately and just
stepped in and did a lot of the mom
things like she was at my baby's birth
she's walking down the aisle she's just
really incredible and in the video you
you have little Snippets of people who
can give shout outs to people who have
saved their life yes you all have a
moment like that we all have you have
somebody like that well all these people
in our lives that have shown up in ways
we could never repay them you know I was
at my show and uh actually in Central
Park here actually and I started to play
save my life and a mother and a daughter
were just like ugly crying I've never
been to a show and like had a song hit
you yeah like crying and dancing at the
same time no you know there's another
song you call that do that's called love
myself which people think Andy Grammer
You're The Happy Guy there's somebody on
Twitter that said thank God for Andy
Grammer because this song has gotten me
through and you know when people think
of you as a happy guy but this song is
actually about a very dark period for
you yay for me you're a happy guy have a
dark period oh my goodness yeah I have
plenty of dark periods especially during
covid yes I think a lot of us did you
know what happened to you Andy what
happened not being able to play shows
not being able to do what I usually do
um just having to spend a lot of alone
time was really difficult for me yeah
and so I was pretty depressed there for
a little bit so I like to speak about it
as much as I possibly can that's good
and it got me into therapy and I'm very
very grateful for all of it
um so then I wrote this song called love
myself after a zoom therapy session I'd
written so many songs for so many other
people that I sat down and wrote myself
a love song think about you yeah you're
a father of two girls yeah
um you have a song Good Man yes you talk
about how they are your inspiration
specifically with this song
um speak a little bit more about how
this came but Nate you know what I think
ever every father that has a daughter
should play this song you know I was
just every father we had my second
daughter in my living room I didn't my
wife did literally in the living in the
living room it was the second week of
covid and so I just had a lot of time
alone at the piano thinking about like
what impact am I going to have on this
little girl I have an older girl too and
um it really was like what what can I
actually do for you and it got me
thinking like what I what my role is as
your father is to be kind of your
example for men yes and so I got to get
better at myself number one and then
just make sure that I
I know you're going to choose a partner
eventually based on how I treat you yeah
and I want that to be as good as
possible I mean you were assistants that
night you didn't write it that night
right uh no I didn't write it at night
because I was there
you go can you get over here
so when inspiration hits honey I'll be
there but as a little girl you're always
taught that your dad will be the first
man that you fall in love with yeah and
the line that struck me in the song you
said if I've done it right only a good
man will feel like home isn't that good
Nate I thought about your little
daughter if I've done it right only a
good man will feel like home because
that's all you'll be attracted to is a
good news yeah and I think when you're a
dad you're consistently thinking about
what am I going to tell my daughters
yeah but what am I going to tell you to
do and something about her being born
was like you're not going to listen to
things I say you're just gonna like take
how I am so what am I going to show you
yeah my example is going to be what you
see and then what you search for right
great response you mentioned in the
pandemic not being able to perform not
being able to tour you are going back on
the road now what's it been like oh man
it's been so great just it's it's uh I
think we all need to sing together yeah
you know yeah there's something that
like community that like breaks the ice
for people I have a lot of people tell
me it shows that they've made friends
for life at the show yeah we need to
sing together and to not be able to do
that for so long until the pandemic is
really hard especially for me yeah it's
really hard no in Anthony's piece when
he was talking about Joy the
singer-songwriter that it's music is one
of the few areas that we can all come
together in yeah not judge and not all
of our differences that's right all of
the differences melt away I love to try
and be someone that you can come to my
show and feel hope
you know it's like a hard time right now
yeah so like it is if we can all come
together and remember that there's a lot
of good things in the world and there's
a lot of good things in ourselves to be
reminded of uh then it's a great night
for me it's almost a pastoral experience
you use the term life proof to talk
about some of your songs can you explain
that quickly yes so life proof to me is
like Isaac Newton
found what gravity was and he wrote it
out and then when everybody read it or
heard it they're like oh totally
you're so good thank you so much for
coming getting up early